[Música]
economía en directo a América ya está
con nosotros en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches vamos a comenzar
hablando de previsiones de crecimiento
global que presentó el Banco Mundial que
nos dicen bueno el organismo firma que
el potencial crecimiento económico del
mundo va a caer hasta el dos coma dos
por ciento para el año 2030 abriendo una
década de pérdida económica una década
perdida le llama el banco Esto A menos
que las autoridades adopten iniciativas
más ambiciosas para impulsar la oferta
de la mano de obra también la
productividad Y por supuesto la
inversión según ellos de cumplirse esta
proyección habrá grandes repercusiones
en la capacidad del mundo para hacer
frente a temas como el cambio climático
y también la reducción de la pobreza el
informe dice que las crisis de los
últimos años como la pandemia del Coby
19 y la invasión rusa de Ucrania suponen
el fin de casi tres décadas de
crecimiento económico sostenido el
organismo también habló de la reciente
crisis de confianza en los bancos
afirman que si esta crisis bancaria se
extiende podría terminar una
desaceleración mucho más aguda del
crecimiento global Pese a que el informe
fue elaborado antes del comienzo de la
crisis que desató el colapso del silicon
hace dos semanas ya mencionaban posibles
crisis bancarias sistémicas que reducen
crecimiento potencial al mediano plazo
Jorge hablemos ahora de Estados Unidos
que demandó por prácticas irregulares a
binance que es la empresa la mayor
empresa que existe criptomonedas en el
mundo bueno la comisión de comercio de
futuros de productos básicos demandó a
esta empresa y a su fundador y consejero
delegado champensado lo acusan de
evasión deliberada de la legislación
estadounidense afirma que vainas esquivó
su responsabilidad al no haberse
registrado en este organismo un paso
necesario para llevar a cabo su
actividad de compra y venta de
criptomonedas en ese país la empresa
está en la mira también de otros
reguladores estadounidenses que están
investigando a la empresa de Sao como la
comisión de bolsa y valores el servicio
interno de impuestos o varios Fiscales
federales la criptodivisa de vainas que
es la cuarta mayor del mundo por tamaño
de Mercado cayó alrededor del 4% tras
conocerse esta noticia vainas es la
mayor plataforma de intercambio de
criptomonedas del mundo Y controla desde
el comercio de bitcoin el arte digital
también hasta el capital de riesgo en
una industria que mueve más de un billón
de dólares hacemos a otro tema Jorge
hablemos ahora de esos despidos masivos
en Estados Unidos ahora es el turno de
Disney que a principios de este año ya
había anunciado los despidos que
comenzaron esta semana
específicamente 7000 despidos en varias
divisiones importantes de esa empresa
Aunque por ahora la cadena ESPN no se ve
afectada por esta Ronda de recursos
durante esta semana sí hay datos que
será incluida en el futuro Disney
comenzará a notificar al primer grupo de
empleados afectados en los próximos
cuatro días una segunda ronda más amplia
se va a producir en abril el
conglomerado de entretenimiento de
burban anunció en Febrero que eliminaría
estos 7.000 puestos de trabajo como
parte de esfuerzo para ahorrarse 5.500
millones de dólares en costos y hacer
rentables su negocio de streaming que en
los últimos meses Está perdiendo
bastante dinero vamos ahora con un tema
de América Latina Venezuela donde
continúan las protestas de los
trabajadores estatales los trabajadores
y también los jubilados que exigen
ingresos dignos para batallar contra la
inflación además de atender necesidades
en escuelas y hospitales los
manifestantes se mostraron indignados
por los desvíos de fondos en Estatal de
petróleos de Venezuela anunciados hace
una semana por el propio Nicolás Maduro
que involucran alto funcionarios que
ahora están detenidos el salario mínimo
en Venezuela equivale a unos 5 dólares
mensuales frente a los 482 dólares que
vale la canasta alimentaria según
estimaciones privadas escuchamos parte
del reclamo
[Música]
de un bloqueo Aquí no hay bloqueo aquí
lo que hay es un saqueo también no hay
dinero resulta que se pierde una
millonada que hoy día todavía Nadie da
explicación con esto ponemos punto final
a la economía a continuación en directo
a América el debate